bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
dépenses économie impôts investissements
nous allons parler budgets en ces temps
troublés par les taxes la baisse des
dotations et autres mécontentement
quelle sera la politique budgétaire de
saint quentin en yvelines pour 2019 et
quel sera son impact sur le quotidien
des saint quentinois ont fait le point
c'est parti
[Musique]
il
ces derniers temps les taxes sont
largement mobilisés les français nous
sommes donc allés voir les saint
quentinois afin qu'ils nous présentent
leur budget pour l'agglomération
si vous étiez à la tête de
l'agglomération ou météores y ait de
l'argent dans les pistes cyclables mais
pas ici forcément entre et l'encours est
ici ouais bon soit partout en sécurité
connaissent pas de se prendre un coup de
rétro ou voilà un coup de neil de
voiture la modernisation parce que c'est
quand même une ville qui date des années
soixante dix en conception et ça sent un
tout petit peu je pense qu'il est bien
me larifou le nettoyage des rues des
jardins trop de béton malgré les parcs
qui sont pas gros mais ça sent pas trop
prise de l'environnement ou
et les espaces extérieurs peut être
aménagée à entretenir davantage rester
ensemble d'affaires attractif voilà que
ça fasse venir plein de gens pour venir
travailler ici éventuellement habitait
pas loin c'est bien aussi
et comme ça ça fait travailler tout le
commerce eu tort
nous nous sommes rendus à l'hôtel
d'agglomération pour connaître les
contours du budget 2010 9
la priorité c'est le développement
économique à saint quentin en yvelines
monlat indiscutablement on a de très
bons résultats et c'est rassurant dans
cette période où en outre diminue les
moyens publics
heureusement que les entreprises sont là
et en gestion n'est je vous rappelle que
sandrine pour ce première agence
mondiale de cotation des collectivités à
cesser si on est on est classés de a
comme une des meilleures notes on de
baisse l'endettement on n'augmente pas
les impôts
on augmente l'activité les entreprises
voilà qui effectivement augmentent leurs
activités et en augmentant leur active
en développement leur activité sur saint
quentin
bien sûr ils augmentent bien sûr leur
contribution et de voilà tout ça ça nous
permet de trouver bien sûr un bon
équilibre
les objectifs principaux du budget 2010
9 respecte ceux de l'an passé et chacun
aura retenu la bonne nouvelle
pas d'augmentation d'impôts premier
objectif
on conserve nos engagements sur le pacte
financier il n'y aura pas d'augmentation
de la fiscalité c'est important les
saint quentinois les français n'en
peuvent plus ils le disent donc à nous
de jouer le jeu aussi un jeu qui se joue
à 12 coming on avait travaillé sur le
plan pluriannuel d'investissement au
mois de
mai dernier au printemps dernier on
s'était mis d'accord d'une manière
relativement consensuelle entre les 12
maires pour reformater notre plan
pluriannuel d'investissement pour qu'il
reflète réellement ce qu'il était
possible de faire à la voie à la fois
financièrement et à la fois sur le temps
au cours des trois prochaines années
un plan pluriannuel prévoit 143 millions
d'investissements de 2018 à 2020
plusieurs projets devraient être ainsi
réaliser d'ici à deux ans parmi lesquels
le forage des tuyaux transportant les
eaux pluviales et potables des travaux
préparatoires à l'enfouissement de la
rn10 à trappes
autre projet l'aménagement du parvis de
la gare de villepreux des clés le but
est de développer la multimodalité du
site dans le cadre d'un contrat de pôle
à la verrière ainsi qu aux
clayes-sous-bois de multiples rue véron
les ampoules des espaces publics
remplacées par des leds en 2018 près de
quatre millions d'euros ont été investis
dans l'entretien et l'amélioration du
réseau de l'éclairage public à montigny
le bretonneux une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire devrait voir le jour
à trappes
les travaux dans la zac de l'aérostat
vont se poursuivre tout ceci dans un
contexte de fortes contraintes
budgétaires en 2018 les élus des douze
communes ou dû réduire les dépenses de
fonctionnement de 2 millions d'euros par
rapport à 2010 est la tendance c'est de
continuer à réduire les dotations aux
structures intercommunales et ovi nous
le savons bien
alors pour pallier cela il ya soit on
augmente massivement les impôts c'est
pas la bonne solution
donc on continue bien sûr de réduire nos
dépenses de fonctionnement mais
qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir nous sauver ce
sont nos entreprises
les entreprises implantées en nombre sur
le territoire permettent d'accroître
l'attractivité de l'agglomération tout
en intensifiant son développement
économique le but aujourd'hui est de
fidéliser ses acteurs et d'en attirer
d'autres tout en favorisant
l'installation de leurs salariés sur
saint quentin en yvelines
pilier de l'économie de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
entreprises automobile aérospatial dont
les finances
dix sept mille entreprises sont
implantées sur saint quentin en yvelines
une présence qui a permis de développer
145 mille emplois les impôts sur les
entreprises permettent de répondre aux
besoins des populations et de poursuivre
les investissements
il faut continuer c'est très important
dans ce budget à avoir une priorité sur
le développement économique de loin qui
nous a sauvés cette année il faut mettre
la priorité absolue sur qu'est ce qui
peut faire que les entreprises
souhaitent venir sur notre territoire et
comment faire qu'elle ne parte pas il ya
des choses qui sont évidentes quand on
connaît l'entreprise
c'est le transport le cadre de vie et
déjà vous avez dit beaucoup de choses et
les écoles les écoles l'éducation est ce
qu'il ya une université est ce qu'il ya
des écoles et ce qui est du transport
est ce qu'il ya des lieux de vie où il
fait bon vivre
est ce que mes cadres est ce que mes
employés vont vouloir venir ici grandes
écoles universités commerce notoriété
autant d'atouts pour attirer les
entreprises
bien sûr
le set extraordinaire événements du
golfe la ryder cup
on a vu ce qu'on avait pas vu au départ
d'ailleurs quand on s'est lancé
là-dedans bon mais ça indiscutablement
augmenter la notoriété de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ca augmenter
notre attractivité on l'a vu il ya des
entreprises qui sont venues qui viennent
sur saint quentin et je peux pas vous
dire exactement mais on sent bien que
l'effet de forte notoriété à jouer sur
l'attractivité même un troisième niveau
ça augmentait la fierté d'appartenance
[Musique]
d'autres domaines sont aussi en pleine
évolution les transports et l'éducation
sont marqués par l'innovation
aménagement de plusieurs pôles gare de
transport collectif en site propre
déploiement de 400 km de pistes
cyclables saint-quentin-en-yvelines joue
la carte de la pluralité un projet de
navette suspendu est en cours
d'élaboration
il devrait être prêt pour les jeux
olympiques 2024 côté formation le
territoire à développer un label école
du numérique afin de répondre à la
demande des entreprises désormais de
multiples organismes dispense des
formations liées au secteur de
l'informatique
ceci pour répondre aux dix mille offres
d'emploi à pourvoir
[Musique]
de nombreux projets locatifs sont aussi
à leurs trappes guyancourt voisins et
montigny le bretonneux des résidences
sortent de terre afin de répondre à la
demande
70% des salariés travaillant sur
l'agglomération vivent encore en
périphérie voici donc pour la fiscalité
2019 très bonne année à toutes et à tous
ciao
[Musique]